[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las noticias
más destacadas a lo largo de la semana
relacionadas con la pandemia del cob y
19 soy santiago lópez gonzález a
continuación les presento el sumario de
temas que tenemos para hoy la pandemia
ha dejado unas altas cifras de desempleo
algunas comienzan ya a mejorar una nueva
brecha también a nivel social y mucha
desigualdad así como nuevas condiciones
laborales porque empezamos a utilizar el
teletrabajo hablaremos del impacto que
ha tenido la pandemia en el mundo
laboral después de 10 meses de
emergencia sanitaria dentro de la
economía si hay un sector que ha sido
fuertemente afectado por la pandemia es
el turismo su reactivación es la suma es
de suma importancia para todos los
países pero este nuevo y de este nuevo
despegue está acompañado de una
renovación de la industria y de un
engranaje entre las autoridades la
industria privada y también los
ciudadanos vamos a analizar el panorama
y en varios países de américa latina en
medio de las restricciones se preparan
para la celebración del día
muertos una de las más importantes
tradiciones de la región pero este año
como es de esperarse por la pandemia
será completamente diferente veremos
cómo es el caso de méxico que se prepara
ya para conmemorar esta fecha comenzamos
pues para iniciar damos primero una
mirada a la situación del continente
americano hasta este cierre de semana de
acuerdo con la organización en corona by
bruce son cada vez menos los países de
la región que parecen acertar en sus
políticas para hacer frente a la crisis
sanitaria porque porque el número de
casos y de víctimas sigue aumentando
esta organización divide en tres colores
ya se los hemos mostrado acá varias
veces en este programa de acuerdo al
desempeño frente a la pandemia en color
verde es decir quienes están siendo
exitosos sobresalen algunos estados
insulares por ejemplo barbados dominica
haití y san cristóbal y nieves en color
amarillo son los países que van llevando
sobrellevando esta crisis y han
evidenciado una leve disminución en los
casos y en el número de las víctimas en
esta categoría se destaca bolivia y
trinidad y tobago y lamentablemente en
color rojo esta organización alerta a
los países que deben tomar medidas
urgentes para reducir sus curvas de
contagio a ser más números de pruebas y
disminuir el número de fallecidos vemos
que una buena
el continente está perdiendo esta
batalla y le cuesta un poco hacer frente
a la pandemia lo vemos desde argentina y
chile- está canadá pasando por
paraguay-venezuela el salvador méxico
república dominicana y cuba entre otros
llama mucho la atención el caso de costa
rica y de uruguay que en un momento
estuvieron en el color verde y fueron
reconocidos a nivel internacional y
ahora son alertados sobre el rápido
avance de tiie que tienen allí de
contagios y de víctimas mortales en
nuestro continente eeuu brasil argentina
y colombia ya superaron la barrera del
millón de contagios
con más de 20 millones de casos
confirmados de kobe 19 que son cerca de
la mitad del total mundial la región de
américa latina y también la región del
caribe son digamos así las más afectadas
por la pandemia del cob y 1934 millones
de empleos se han perdido a lo largo de
estos meses en estas dos regiones por lo
que la organización internacional del
trabajo ha alertado sobre el posible
aumento de desigualdades laborales sobre
todo entre las mujeres y los jóvenes
veamos
alrededor de 34 millones de empleos se
han perdido durante la pandemia en
américa latina y el caribe esto según la
organización internacional del trabajo
oit que también indicó que la crisis
actual ha tenido un impacto inmediato
sobre los países de la región asociado
al cierre de las economías y a las
medidas de confinamiento y
distanciamiento lo que también ha
llevado a una notoria caída en la
demanda las mujeres y los jóvenes son
los más afectados el informe muestra que
1 de cada 6 jóvenes perdieron su trabajo
desde la aparición del virus los jóvenes
trabajadores entre las edades de 18 a 24
años y aquellos que trabajan en labores
administrativas en ventas en artesanías
o en servicios fueron particularmente
afectados con la pérdida de trabajo
el fondo monetario internacional prevé
una caída del producto interno bruto
regional del 94 por ciento en perú la
reducción será del 13 9% en méxico del
11 por ciento en argentina del 9,9 por
ciento en brasil del 9,1 por ciento y en
colombia del 78 por ciento ayurvédico no
me crítica berisso ni una recuperación
económica sostenible sólo es posible si
vencemos la pandemia y si la vencemos en
todas partes o houts meier es nuestro
imperativo intensificar las medidas
sanitarias vitales para facilitar el
apoyo fiscal y monetario a los hogares y
empresas
a pesar de que en los últimos meses se
han mejorado las proyecciones económicas
y laborales para 2021 en la región la
hoy te asegura que en medio de la
recuperación el déficit de trabajo
formal se hará más evidente para los
jóvenes las mujeres y los adultos con
menores calificaciones expertos aseguran
que la clave de la crisis que enfrenta
la región es adoptar estrategias
tempranas para atenuar los impactos por
lo que alientan a los gobiernos a
fortalecer políticas que beneficien a
trabajadores vulnerables ya pequeñas y
medianas empresas con el fin de evitar
un panorama aún más grave en 2021
[Música]
para analizar este tema conversamos con
carmen bueno ella es especialista en
seguridad y salud en el trabajo de la
organización internacional del trabajo
nos atiende desde la ciudad de santiago
en chile- señora bueno gracias por estar
con nosotros a esta hora en france 24 y
cuáles son esas principales lecciones
que deja en estos 10 meses de emergencia
de emergencia sanitaria la pandemia del
coronavirus vemos que el desempleo
claramente es una de las secuelas
importantes que dejan la región
hola buenas noches santiago es difícil
la verdad extraer lecciones de una
situación en la que todavía estamos
inmersos y que además plantea una gran
incertidumbre respecto a su evolución lo
que genera inevitablemente mayores
dificultades para conjeturar estas
lecciones no tenemos más que ver esa
segunda ola del virus en europa
indudablemente el mercado de trabajo va
a cambiar y va a cambiar notoriamente y
dada la profundidad de la crisis vamos a
tener consecuencias a corto medio y
largo plazo quizá una lección importante
que aquellos países con una
institucionalidad más fuerte con menos
informalidad laboral y con sistemas de
protección social más consolidados tanto
respecto a su cobertura como al nivel de
prestaciones van a sufrir un menor
impacto en la medida en que van a poder
implementar políticas para sostener a
las empresas para sostener los puestos
de trabajo y también para garantizar
ingresos a los trabajadores
y a las familias pero incluso también
estamos viendo que países con mayores
debilidades igualmente están adoptando
de una manera rápida políticas en este
sentido y que son coherentes con el
marco general de políticas de respuesta
que ha propuesto la white entonces cómo
empezar a recuperar un poco los números
porque igual pues ya lo estamos diciendo
la pandemia continúa no hay vacuna no
cambian dadas las condiciones y la
región de américa latina en particular
tuvo un encuentro muy brusco con la
implementación del teletrabajo porque no
estaba habituada y no estaba preparada
para este tipo de prácticas como
entonces revertir un poco las cosas
bueno yo creo que también en primer
lugar es importante recordar que esta
pandemia encontró a la región ya en un
contexto de desaceleración económica y
de ralentización incluso en algunos
casos de reversión de algunas mejoras
laborales que se habían venido
observando en los últimos años y a esto
además hay que sumarle algunas
características estructurales como son
la informalidad laboral el nivel
reducido de ingresos y las debilidades
en los sistemas de protección social y
de salud por lo tanto no sorprende que
el impacto de esta crisis mundial en la
región vaya a ser especialmente
virulento pero como hemos visto algunos
países que ya adoptaron medidas están
ofreciendo ya algunas caídas en las
cifras de desempleo y además se da esa
circunstancia y es que bueno pues subo
una de las medidas de hecho
comúnmente adoptada por los países fue
precisamente la adopción del teletrabajo
y que fue de alguna forma un beneficio
para seguir continuando con las
actividades productivas al menos las que
podían ser realizadas y desarrolladas a
través de esta modalidad cumpliendo a su
vez las restricciones sanitarias sobre
el tema del trabajo le quería preguntar
qué tan desentendida estaba la región de
américa latina con el teletrabajo como
una práctica laboral común que ya
incluso es habitual en algunos países
del norte de europa por ejemplo en
suecia en noruega y en dinamarca
yo no diría que al menos
legislativamente estuviera tan
desatendida al menos en mi país en
españa' la regulación sobre el
teletrabajo es bastante reciente y forma
parte de las respuestas a la pandemia en
cambio algunos países de américa latina
ya habían avanzado anteriormente en la
regulación del teletrabajo o estaban en
el proceso de avanzar sin ir más lejos
colombia ya había regulado en el año
2008 las garantías sindicales y de
seguridad social de los teletrabajadores
pero también había avanzado en el 2013
brasil costa rica y únicamente algunos
países que ya habían empezado los
procesos regulatorios el año pasado los
concluyeron a principios de este año
antes de que la pandemia llegara a la
región como es el caso de panamá del
salvador y de chile únicamente en el
caso de argentina se aprobó más
recientemente en agosto y en uruguay
está todavía en proceso de tramitación
parlamentaria por lo menos esa
preparación normativa sí que existió sin
embargo no podemos obviar
que como usted decía la transición fue
muy brusca y esa nota junto a otras
características hacen que quizá en el
caso del teletrabajo en pandemia
tengamos que hablar de un concepto
distinto como es el trabajo remoto
obligatorio y excepcional y no el
teletrabajo al menos como lo conocíamos
con anterioridad a la pandemia
importante es aclaración que hace usted
en esta última acotación qué tan
beneficioso ha sido para américa latina
el teletrabajo tengamos en cuenta que
aquí hay unas grandes desigualdades en
cuanto a tecnología acceso a internet y
en facilidad de acceso a nuevas
tecnologías
yo creo que de teletrabajo y el trabajo
a distancia como mencionábamos antes ha
sido una de las medidas más promovidas
por los gobiernos no sólo en la región
sino a nivel mundial durante esta crisis
sanitaria para mantener empleos y para
poder garantizar la continuidad de
algunas actividades productivas que
obviamente sí que permiten esta
modalidad de organización del trabajo
sobre la que nosotros hemos venido
advirtiendo y tratando de impulsar
nuevos marcos regulatorios desde
prácticamente el año 2015 el teletrabajo
al menos el que se producía con
anterioridad a la pandemia ofrecía
ventajas a los trabajadores los
teletrabajadores se encontraban en el
teletrabajo una mejor forma de
equilibrar y conciliar la vida
profesional de vida laboral con la vida
familiar de eliminar por ejemplo en los
desplazamientos a los lugares de trabajo
que en las grandes ciudades sabemos que
suponen un gran problema y también para
las empresas suponía la adopción de
arreglos más
en la jornada de trabajo sin embargo es
importante evitar que estas ventajas
puedan convertirse en inconvenientes y
generar una precarización laboral y por
eso es importante que estos marcos
normativos que se está avanzando en la
región establezcan un catálogo de
derechos laborales mínimos y que son
exactamente los mismos que deberían
garantizarse para el resto de los
trabajadores con eso responde usted un
poco mi siguiente pregunta sobre la
regulación que es necesaria entonces
para garantizarle cosas muy básicas a
los empleados asisten en trabajo en
remoto que se debe tener en cuenta
entonces para organizar esos marcos de
regulación para los países que todavía
no lo tiene cuáles son los aspectos que
usted cree que deben ser fundamentales y
que no deben obviarse
bueno en primer lugar como decíamos a
diferencia del teletrabajo en pandemia
el teletrabajo tradicional tiene un
carácter voluntario y eso es algo que
debería reflejarse en los nuevos marcos
regulatorios debería garantizarse el
derecho a un salario digno a un régimen
de protección social por supuesto a una
limitación de la jornada de trabajo y a
su distribución incluyendo por ejemplo
como tiene en el caso de las
legislaciones argentinas chilena y otras
legislaciones en el mundo el derecho a
la desconexión digital es decir
garantizar que el trabajador durante su
descanso no está obligado a responder
requerimientos por parte del empleador a
través de distintas tecnologías de la
información y comunicaciones en el
trabajo también se deberán garantizar
condiciones de seguridad y salud laboral
incluyendo la salud mental que
puede verse especialmente deteriorada
durante este régimen de teletrabajo en
pandemia habrá que regular también la
obligación del empleador de proveer al
trabajador de los equipos de los medios
y de todos los recursos que sean
necesarios y también la protección de
los datos el derecho a la intimidad del
trabajador y sobre todo la posibilidad
de sistemas de vigilancia que pueden
afectar a los mismos y derechos
fundamentales como la libertad sindical
y la negociación colectiva señora bueno
muchas gracias por estar con nosotros en
france 24 debo avanzar con otros temas
que tenemos en el programa muchas
gracias por explicarnos aquí a la
teleaudiencia de france 24 nos vamos
ahora hasta argentina allí las
autoridades se vieron obligadas a
desalojar a los residentes ilegales en
un terreno baldío muy cerca de la ciudad
de buenos aires- la capital se trata de
familias que abandonaron sus hogares por
no tener la capacidad económica para
pagar sus alquileres después de haber
perdido sus empleos por el avance de la
pandemia esta es la historia
como si se tratara de una guerra civil
una línea de policías fue acercándose
lentamente decenas de personas los
esperaban con escudos de plástico
piedras y palos cerca de 4.000 agentes
fueron movilizados para vaciar este
terreno baldío que se había convertido
en el hogar de 1200 familias se acercó
un policía me dijo que no teníamos que
retirar
yo le dije que quería sacar mis cosas y
me dijo que mañana iba a poder venir a
salvar a mi cosa entonces le pedí por
favor que me dejara sacar leche pañales
dinero un poco de ropa para mis hijos y
me fui la llegada del cob y 19
argentinas agudizó una recesión
establecida en el país desde 2018 en
total cerca de 3000 personas se
asentaron en este campo y luego de
dialogar con el gobierno provincial
algunos partieron voluntariamente pero
aún quedaban cerca de 200 el gobierno ha
prometido subsidios de hasta 600 dólares
mensuales durante seis meses y refugios
temporales pero esto no bastó para
convencerlos a todos de partir
al mismo tiempo en la capital argentina
miembros de partidos de izquierda y
activistas marcharon en contra del
desalojo es decir acá hay un repudio muy
grande y es un repudio que se va a
profundizar porque acá se tiene que
resolver no solo el problema de la
familia que ahora están en la calle sino
también del resto de la calle que no
encontró quizás un canal para expresar
esa desesperación de no poder ciudad a
fin de mes no tener un techo donde
dormir en el primer trimestre del año la
tasa de desempleo en argentina fue del
10,4 por ciento según las proyecciones
de la consultora ecolatina la tasa para
el segundo trimestre habría subido al 14
por ciento
eeuu celebrará unos esperados comicios
presidenciales el próximo 3 de noviembre
unas elecciones marcadas por la pandemia
que ha llevado a que sean adoptadas
algunas medidas de bioseguridad y un
impulso en mayor medida al voto
anticipado este país lidera el ranking a
nivel mundial en cuanto a la cantidad de
contagios y de víctimas
el presidente de donald trump indicó que
los estados que cuentan con un
gobernador demócrata son los más
afectados por el coronavirus esta es una
afirmación que no tiene ningún tipo de
fundamento científico pero veamos un
poco más en detalle en el siguiente mapa
que les vamos a presentar los 10 estados
más afectados en su orden son california
con más de 920.000 casos es un estado
que tiene un gobernador demócrata le
siguen texas y florida que están en
poder de los republicanos nueva york e
illinois están en manos de los
demócratas le sigue
georgia en atún el gobernador es el
republicano en la siguiente
escala encontramos a carolina del norte
que está en manos de los demócratas y
tennessee y arizona que están en manos
de los republicanos finalmente cierra
este top 10 new jersy que está en manos
de los demócratas así vemos entonces que
el top 10 está repartido en cinco para
cada uno de los partidos ya sacarán los
entonces ustedes las conclusiones en
cuanto a esa afirmación que ha hecho el
presidente de donald trump en cuanto a
que los los estados que están en peores
condiciones son los que están gobernados
por los demócratas mucho tinte político
vale la pena decir esto coincide también
con que esta semana eeuu superó los 9
millones de casos confirmados
con más de 90.000 nuevos casos de
coronavirus en 24 horas en eeuu se está
hundiendo más en la crisis el número de
hospitalizaciones también está
aumentando y la situación podría
empeorar aún más
nos enfrentamos a uno de los picos más
altos que hemos tenido en toda la
pandemia y 910 meses después del
principio todavía no estamos preparados
no hay las pruebas que necesitamos hay
muchos problemas con muchos brotes en
muchas zonas del país y nos adentraremos
en el otoño y el invierno lo que por
supuesto muy clara muy muy difícil de
fecode doce estados registraron números
récord de contagios el jueves pero las
estadísticas están aumentando en 47 de
los 50 estados
el equipo de crisis de la casa blanca
advierte que el virus se está
extendiendo por todo el país las
autoridades locales están tomando la
delantera como aquí en wisconsin donde
se han abierto varios centros de pruebas
en nuevo méxico se pide a los residentes
que se sometan estrictamente a las
normas sanitarias por temor al colapso
de los hospitales
una vez más el número de pacientes está
aumentando significativamente y está
creciendo ya hemos triplicado el volumen
de pacientes en el hospital en menos de
un mes y continúa y los números son aún
más altos ahora
unos días antes de las elecciones los
llamados del candidato demócrata joe
biden para hacer obligatorio el uso de
la máscara en todo el país están ganando
terreno el destacado experto en
enfermedades infecciosas anthony fauci
dijo que apoya la idea aunque es
probable que tal medida sea cuestionada
legalmente el presidente de donald trump
por su parte aún no está convencido
y si hay una industria afectada por la
pandemia es la industria turística que a
su vez involucra a diferentes sectores
como la aviación los transportes
hotelería restaurantes turoperadores y
producción local por ejemplo de las
artesanías cómo está la perspectiva de
recuperación en esta industria
más temprano conversamos con maribel
rodríguez ella es vicepresidenta senior
del consejo mundial de viajes y turismo
y comenzamos por preguntarle las
lecciones que les deja hasta el momento
estos 10 meses de emergencia sanitaria
en la industria turística mundial
pues desafortunadamente muchísimas
gracias por cortar con nosotros si todo
continúa tal y como lo tenemos previsto
más de 174 millones de empleos se van a
perder en todo el planeta lo cual
significa bueno una mejora con respecto
a las previsiones anteriores que eran
197 como consecuencia que en lugares
como china el turismo doméstico ha
mejorado y ha suavizado esta situación
pero en el resto de los lugares aún no
no estás a ese nivel con lo cual podrían
ser 143 millones de empleos lo que se
han perdido ya a día de hoy también le
preguntamos a la señora rodríguez siendo
ésta una industria tan amplia que como
ya decíamos abarca el sector aeronáutico
los hoteles la gastronomía la industria
local de manufacturas le preguntamos
cuáles son los sectores más afectados
dentro de la gran industria turística
esto fue lo que nos dijo
pues toda la cadena de valor se ha visto
afectada porque todos están conectados
los unos con los otros evidentemente los
más afectados han sido las compañías
aéreas como consecuencia de la relación
directa que tienen con todo lo que es el
viaje tanto de ocio como de negocio pero
como podéis imaginar todo el resto de la
cadena de valoración afectada compañías
aéreas hoteles distribuidoras algunos
han mejorado relativamente por el tema
del turismo doméstico pero no podemos
decir que a día de hoy haya un sector
mal calificado que el otro que permea
toda la sociedad permea toda la cadena
de valor y no solamente afecta a las
compañías sino todo lo que va dejando
atrás de ellas porque los empleos
directos indirectos e inducidos que el
turismo tiene son muy importantes y a
nivel social muy preocupantes
a propósito del avance de la segunda ola
de contagio de coronavirus en europa le
preguntamos a la señora rodríguez qué
lecciones debe tener en cuenta a américa
del sur sobre todo teniendo en cuenta
que el hemisferio sur entra en la
temporada alta de verano en las próximas
semanas y ya vemos lo que está pasando
en europa esto fue lo que nos comentó
coordinación público-privada que los
gobiernos se coordinen utilización de
tests a la salida en origen pueden
utilizar luego otro y otro por supuesto
para la utilización de plataformas que
permitan tener un contacto un trabajo se
trate y se empape los casos positivos
para poder actuar quirúrgicamente
aquellos pasos que que son positivos la
implementación de protocolos sanitarios
y protocolos de viaje uso de mascarillas
a distancia social todo esto de manera
conjunta facilitaría la posibilidad de
poder seguir viajando normalmente cuando
se aplica eso sin duda hay una mejoría
estamos trabajando nosotros desde desde
octubre le presentamos a los países del
g20 entre los cuales se encuentran
algunos países de la región y con los
cuales trabajamos un manual de 12 puntos
en los cuales el sector privado mundial
nos comprometíamos a trabajar
conjuntamente con el sector público para
recuperar 100 millones de empleos en
todo el planeta estamos en esta en esta
fase ahora de trabajo conjunto de
coordinación
y poder llevarlo a cabo pero es muy
importante hacer caso y seguir estos
protocolos hacer uso de los test porque
es la única manera de no perder
tantísimos puestos de trabajo y el
impacto social que esto puede tener en
la región
hablábamos con la señora rodríguez sobre
las lecciones que nos deja esto para la
industria turística pero también le
preguntamos si esto representa un antes
y un después en la industria del turismo
y un momento de coyuntura en el que
puede renovarse o incluso redescubrirse
bueno obviamente la digitalización y la
sostenibilidad la cuidado del medio
ambiente se ha acelerado era ya lo que
estaba parte de la agenda con lo cual
bueno esta oportunidad la podemos tomar
ahora para utilizarla y llevarla a cabo
pero realmente en este momento lo que
tenemos que preocuparnos es de ser
competitivos de trabajar ahora de hacer
ahora formación de trabajar mucho en la
digitalización de las empresas y de
poder hacer unos trabajos conjuntos
entre las empresas y los destinos para
la producción futura internacional
porque luego va a haber hay muchísimas
empresas y muchísimos destinos
queriéndose posicionar y es el momento
de hacer el trabajo y no nos olvidemos
de las empresas los apoyos necesarios
para que el sector privado y el empleo
siga ahí una vez que ha pasado la
pandera porque la panera pasar a llegar
a la vacuna pero hasta que simplemente
la vacuna hay que seguir conviviendo con
esta vacuna y seguir trabajando nuestros
protocolos y hay que ayudar al sector
privado y hay que utilizar las mejores
prácticas impulso financiero revisión de
los impuestos hay que ayudar a las
empresas para que mantengan a su puerta
de trabajo
para que puedan estar ahí una vez que la
pandemia haya pasado
estos mejores ejemplos lo podemos ver en
países como por ejemplo en italia en
eeuu perdón en reino unido en españa en
francia que han apoyado el sector
privado obviamente siempre se les puede
apoyar más pero han mantenido la fuerza
laboral al empleo lo cual es muy
importante y ahora con ciertos
incentivos que se están realizando en
ciertas partes de europa como fue por
ejemplo en italia que implementaron el
bono de viajar dentro de la región el
viaje doméstico va a ser muy importante
y nos consta que buenos aires que que
argentina también está trabajando en
este tipo de promoción que son muy
interesantes para promocionar el viaje
dentro de los países también para que
faciliten los flujos y que haya también
estos movimientos que faciliten y que
dejen dinero en las economías locales
ella menciona el turismo interno
entonces en ese orden de ideas mi
siguiente pregunta para nuestra invitada
fue si precisamente el turismo interno
era ese punto de partida para la
reconstrucción de la industria en los
países de américa latina que sin duda
alguna son un poco más pequeñas que las
que hay en otros países de europa
una larga tradición turística como
grecia italia españa o francia
el turismo en todo es muy bueno para
mantener para y es lo que ha pasado en
china en china han utilizado el turismo
interno para poder promocionar para
poder seguir trabajando para poder
continuar la normalidad pero nosotros
abogamos por que se abran las fronteras
y que haya se vuelva a reanudar el viaje
internacional para lo cual hay una serie
de protocolos y para lo cual algunas
medidas que implementando esas medidas
se puede garantizar la seguridad no no
confundamos que el 10,4 por ciento del
3% del pib mundial corresponde a los
viajes y el turismo y el turismo
internacional es muy importante no
solamente es el turismo de ocio es el
turismo de negocio son las reuniones y
es todo lo que tiene que ver con la
economía sin nunca olvidar el componente
sanitario que tiene que por supuesto
estar implementado en toda la cadena de
valor no estamos diciendo que no se
viaje a nivel internacional estamos
diciendo que se puede viajar a nivel
internacional no se pueden cerrar las
fronteras se tiene que abrir las
fronteras utilizando todos los medios
oportunos pero que a la vez el turismo
doméstico también tiene que estimular se
para poder mantener la economía
preservar la entrevista que tuvimos un
poco más temprano con maribel rodríguez
a quien agradecemos por haber estado con
aquí en france24 vicepresidenta senior
del consejo mundial de viajes y turismo
que nos aclaró muchos puntos de esta
importante industria mundial en nuestra
sección en redes veamos otras noticias
destacadas de la semana aquí en kobe 19
la semana en américa vamos a comenzar
con este anuncio canadá podría ayudar a
guyana a desarrollar una app para hacer
seguimiento a los pacientes con móvil 19
un anuncio de cooperación que llega
cuando el país suramericano y
considerable tiene un aumento
considerable en el número de casos de
contagio y esto ya está empezando a
rebasar su capacidad para hacer
seguimiento a los casos es muy reducida
la capacidad que tiene este país en
guyana tiene más de 1.400 casos ya
conocidos y unas 123 personas han
fallecido hasta el momento una cifra que
es muy alta si tenemos en cuenta que
guyana solamente tiene 500.000
habitantes y tiene un sistema hospital
hospitalario muy deficiente y pequeño
que se concentra básicamente en la
capital
georgetown
vamos a otras noticias destacada este
anuncio hecho por las autoridades
peruanas preocupó también a nivel
regional de a nivel internacional perú
confirmó el primer caso de difteria en
20 años este caso fue descubierto
precisamente en una inspección sanitaria
como medida para hacer frente al
coronavirus sobre todo en los barrios
menos favorecidos del ihma la capital la
paciente es una menor de edad que no
recibió el ciclo completo de vacunación
contra la difteria la coyuntura de la
pandemia siempre el temor de la posible
activación de otras enfermedades
en este caso como difteria como lo
mencionábamos o incluso el sarampión
y hablamos ahora de canadá y más de
10.000 fallecidos ya fueron
contabilizados en ese país
norteamericano el primer ministro justin
foto advirtió sobre posibles tiempos
difíciles el incremento de los casos
obedece a las celebraciones del día de
acción de gracias' canadiense a
comienzos del mes de octubre y ha tenido
mayor incidencia sobre todo en las
poblaciones o provincias más habitadas o
más pobladas como son ontario quebec
columbia británica alberta y
saskatchewan la menor incidencia tienen
lugar en territorios más aislados al
norte del territorio de liu con la isla
del príncipe eduardo en el atlántico
canadiense y la provincia de terranova
terranova y labrador el premier
canadiense calificó esta situación como
una horrible tragedia nacional
y la tradición del día de los muertos
está bien extendida en la región de
américa latina pero ningún país lo vive
más que méxico en donde los ciudadanos
tendrán que celebrar de una manera muy
diferente cómo será precisamente esa
celebración se lo contamos a
continuación
aunque las calles de la ciudad de mexico
se pinten de naranja como lo prevé la
tradición la capital vivirá este año una
celebración del día de muertos insólita
pues diferente va a ser diferente porque
en casa no siempre salimos nos
disfrazábamos fiestas todos los equipos
africanos a poder pero pues es algo que
pasajeros pero nos aproximan y se puede
hacer y eso lo que vamos a hacer es
esperar a que pase la pandemia ella saca
en efecto del 31 de octubre al 2 de
noviembre los casi 120 panteones del
área metropolitana de la capital
permanecerán cerrados para impedir
aglomeraciones ante la pandemia de ccoo
y 19 lo que ha llevado a los mexicanos a
honrar sus difuntos con antelación pues
sí es triste para mucha gente que un
ejemplo nosotros que vimos que nada más
cada año y de repente el día que vamos a
venir no lo podemos hacer pues no nos
nos hace justo el gobierno creo que se
equivocan un al cementerio sólo dejan
entrar un máximo de tres personas por
familia lo que significa que los más de
700 mil turistas nacionales
nacionales que inundan habitualmente los
cementerios tampoco podrán admirar esa
celebración catalogada como patrimonio
cultural inmaterial de la humanidad por
la unesco corremos mucho riesgo entonces
está bien que nos hayan permitido venir
a dejarle nuestro nuestras flores
plantas están nuestros muertos y sobre
todo pues acompañadas a undiano la
alcaldesa de la ciudad de méxico claudia
james bond que dio positivo en la prueba
de que hoy 19 esta semana instó a la
población a celebrar el día de muertos
en casa y por otra parte durante estas
fiestas
el gobierno mexicano decretará tres días
de luto nacional por los fallecidos de
ccoo y 19
y este fue nuestro resumen de noticias
de kobe 19 la semana en américa los
invito para que dejen sus preguntas y
sus comentarios a través de las redes
sociales otras noticias también las
encuentran en france 24 punto com en las
redes sociales y en la app descargando
la en su teléfono móvil
nosotros nos volvemos a ver la próxima
semana con otro resumen de noticias
relacionadas con la pandemia del cobi 19
feliz fin de semana
[Música]